herzlich willkommen martin baumann war
der sternstunde religion dann können wir
sicher sein dass wir sprechen heute über
religion und integration
sie sind deutscher in namibia geboren
haben in england und deutschland
studiert leben nun aber schon zwölf
jahre in der schweiz sind sie selbst
integriert ich würde sagen ja ich würde
bin integriert wir haben viele meine
familie und ich viele schweizer freunde
im quartier wo wir wohnen sind wir sehr
gut vernetzt ich helfe beispielsweise
mal bei turmführungen der katholischen
kirche mit meine frau ist sehr gut
integriert indem sie unterricht für
migrantinnen gibt und mir fällt aber sie
brauchen im konjunktiv ich würde sagen
dass das heißt sie empfinden so gibt es
dann auch ein objektives feststellen
ihrer ihres integriert sein ich habe den
konjunktiv gebraucht weil er integration
letztendlich eine form ist die von außen
zugeschrieben wird die sozusagen die
mehrheitsgesellschaft gruppen personen
zu schreibt oder nicht von daher ist
sicherlich das eigene empfinden ich
fühle mich sehr gut integriert aber ob
das andere so sehen das kann ich selber
kontrollieren dadurch oder mit bekommen
indem er es anderen sagen dem sie
beispielsweise mit mir schweizerdeutsch
reden dann ist es eine form von
integration
aber wenn ich auf einem straßenfest mein
deutsches bier trinke da ist mir auch
schon gesagt worden du musst dir das
lokale biertrinken dass ich nicht mag um
integriert zu sein ärgert dass sie
eigentlich wenn sie auf ihre integration
angesprochen werden ich
weiß es nicht mehr also ich finde es ich
versuche es analytisch zu sehen und
frage mich warum ist diese große
sehr große wut sagen fokus auf dieser
integration in der schweizer
gesellschaft meines erachtens klappt
hier sehr viele sehr gut und ich wundere
mich warum sozusagen diese thematik
problematik so oft hervorgeholt wird der
schweiz ist ein
hatten sehr viele sachen extrem gut und
ich finde es eine thematik die diese
zeigen ein bisschen schwächer auch bei
vielen schweizern zeigt dass immer
wieder hervorholen wir kommen darauf
zurück sie forschen an der uni luzern
sind religionswissenschaftler und
warschau denken sie schon seit langem
sehr intensiv mit fragen der zuwanderung
von religiösen gemeinschaften und ihrer
gesellschaftlichen integration
ich bin muslimin ich bin in der schweiz
geboren habe einen arabischen und einen
europäischen elternteil wie weiß ich
denn jetzt ob ich integriert bin
ja das ist das ist die problematik ist
wird ich glaube es wird zugeschrieben
einmal die integration ich glaube für
viele wenn wir gerade auf viele
schweizer auf viele die sozusagen
immigranten sind die schweizer sind
schauen sie fühlen sich integriert wenn
sie die sprache sprechen wenn sie einen
job haben wenn sie sozial beruflich
eingegliedert sind finden sie auch
beispielsweise auf bestimmte anlässe
eingeladen werden wenn sie
beispielsweise im interreligiösen
kreisen wird jetzt der hindu priester
bei uns in luzern eingeladen das ist
eine geste die vorher nicht
stattgefunden hat wenn die universität
luzern jetzt nicht nur mehr der den
kirchenvertretern zu ihren dies
academicus einlädt sondern auch andere
religionsvertreter ich denke dass seine
öffnung und es ist ein zeichen er gehört
dazu wir möchten euch dabei haben welt
integration aber ein oder das integriert
sei nur von außen zugeschrieben wird
dann kann der einzelne zu integrieren da
ja im prinzip ja gar nichts dazu
beitragen doch er kann sehr viel deutsch
beitrag in dem er teilnimmt in dem sich
einbringt der schweiz ist es sehr
deutlich anzeichen für eine mitglied zu
sein ich glaube integration durch viel
darüber ob man sich austausch mit
anderen in der straße im quartier in der
schule in der universität sankt
teilnimmt an den angeboten einer
gesellschaft und in dem sinne ist
natürlich wichtig zu nachzudenken was
heißt integration eigentlich und ich
verstehe integration als teilhabe als
teilhaber an den angeboten ressourcen
einer gesellschaft und hier haben für
dich sagen doch großteil der migranten
haben sehr hochgradig anteil an dieser
gesellschaft in der schule
arbeitsbereiche und ähnlichen teilhaben
und was genau oder wo genau kommt jetzt
die regierung ins spiel wenn es um
integration geht integration kommt ins
spiel fall fremde religion grad
muslimische mitunter auch tamilisch
egoistische wird als sozusagen als ein
störfaktor gesehen als ein
hinderungsgrund dass man nicht guter
muslim sein kann und zugleich guter
schweizer sein kann sie finden was geht
ich finde das geht es ja deutlich
gerade weil in der schweizer
gesellschaft auch in anderen
europäischen gesellschaft bezwang
religion ist seien bei vielen ein
teilbereich ist und nicht mehr der
hauptbestandteil von einem religiösen
von einem leben in der gesellschaft an
und wir haben sehr deutlich gesehen in
den studien sagen religiös seien stabile
hinduistisch sei es tibetisch
buddhistischen muslimisch und später
bürger eines landes zu sein ist kein
widerspruch und das sehen wir in der
religionsgeschichte show und wir sehen
es einfach am täglichen zusammenleben
wenn wir mit personen entsprechen und
religion steht dort nicht so oft mehr im
vordergrund
sie haben ein buch herausgegeben mit
kollegen das heißt integration durch
religion mit einem dicken fragezeichen
versehen
sie versprechen geschichtliche befunde
analysen und perspektiven die frage wie
steht es denn um die antworten scheut
sich die wissenschaft eindeutige
antworten zu heben nein sie gibt
antworten aber sie gibt unterschiedliche
sie differenziert sie unterscheidet und
es kommt eben sehr deutlich darauf an
wie sie verstehe ich integration
letztendlich verstehe ich integration
wie ich sie jetzt definiert habe als
teilhaber als eine möglichkeit an der
gesellschaft sich einzubringen eine
ressourcen teilzunehmen oder ist
integration bislang verstanden wird und
wie es auch gesellschaftspolitisch in
vielen kreisen verstand wird eigentlich
anpassung anpassung an die bedingungen
der gesellschaften damit sind die
rahmenbedingungen der gesellschaft
gesetzt dann und das ist assimilation
und wie wir in unseren gesprächen die
ich sehe ist diese assimilation oft eine
aufgabe von hergebrachten bezügen sei es
familien bezügen sei es bestimmten
bezügen wie ich selber mich als person
einbringe da das ich sozusagen meine
eigenheit meine identitäten auch wahren
möchte und in dem sinne ist assimilation
nicht notwendig ein konzept was jetzt zu
einer anerkennung auch der immigranten
führt der zugezogene personen aber haben
wir nicht ein dilemma sie haben gesagt
wie sie ist integration in erster linie
teilhabe partizipation
die mehrheitsgesellschaft wirklich
behaupten sie dass er als eine anpassung
an die hiesigen gepflogenheiten werden
immer wieder hervorgehoben an die er
sich anzupassen gilt wie bringen wie
bringen wir jetzt diese beiden
extreme sozusagen zusammen ich denke im
alltag läuft läuft sehr viel schon
miteinander sehr gut zusammen indem
diese teilhabe eben auch niederschwellig
ist dass sie in teilhabe in beruflichen
beruflichen teil beruflichen bereichen
da ist die kinder werden in den schulen
integriert bekommen hier eben auch die
kontakte da und sind nimmt teil an mit
erster ausbildung ein höherer ausbildung
dann und es ist eine teilhabe die jetzt
eben nicht die sehr viel spannen breiten
hat und ein spektrum aufzeigt dann und
wir haben eben moderne gesellschaft
ausdifferenzierte gesellschaft das heißt
verschiedene bereich haben wir in der
nicht notwendig in allen bereichen
teilhabe ist aber ich denke sehr wichtig
für zugezogene ist die primäre wie vor
kurz vor der gründung teilhabe ist
beruflich ein leader zu sein sozial
eingeliefert sein er sei es in
jugendgruppen soll es in jugendclubs den
sportverein und so etwas und da sehe ich
doch sehr viel positives was auch läuft
sie
streichen das positive hervor was schon
gut läuft wenn wir den öffentlichen
diskurs uns anschauen dann tönt sehr
viel anders
es ist ein politikum es ist ein heißes
eisen
wie sehen sie denn das wieviel musste
der staat vorschreiben an integration
das ist in der tat ein ein heißes eisen
ist es die frage ob der staat dies
überhaupt vorschreibt oder ob es nicht
in der zivilgesellschaft vorgeschrieben
wird das heißt durch politische parteien
beispielsweise durch meinungsmacher dann
und ich sehe den schweizer staat
eigentlich wenn ich mit behörden zu tun
habe sehe ich ihn eigentlich relativ
entspannt gerade wenn wir die muslimin
frage und die besagen die islam diskurs
sieht ich sehe behördenvertreter auf der
nationalen ebene bundesrats eben auf
lokalen gemeinden eigentlich eher
entspannter relativieren
differenzierende und ich sehe politische
parteien die ja nie vielleicht auch die
unterschiedlichkeit von muslimen seien
in der schweizer gesellschaft nicht so
sehr sehen und ein einheitliches bild
zeigen dann ich denke man muss sehen
dass ist es ist nicht nur alles
sozusagen positiv in den immigranten
verein man muss auch sehen es wert
bestimmter druck ausgeübt teilzunehmen
oder vielleicht bestimmte rollen
einzunehmen für frauen für männer dann
also
vereinheitlichten nur das verherrlichen
was in den verein läuft das möchte ich
auch nicht sagen bleiben wir noch einen
moment sie haben eben die islam diskurs
frage angesprochen es heißt ja immer
wieder muslime sind integrierbar der
islam aber nicht stehen sie zu solchen
aussagen
ich glaube auch hier muss man einfach
sehen es wird ja pauschalisierend
gesprochen und dann versucht eben dann
sich sozusagen dann noch raus zu retten
ich glaube einmal man muss einfach sehr
deutlich sagt islam ist eine gelebte
religion und sie wird in der schweiz
wenn wir uns anschauen wie erst
immigranten wie die jugendlichen das
leben wie es ihnen eigentlich der
großteil ist relativ distanziert
gegenüber der eigenen religion kommen
auf die thematik der zweiten generation
in dem sinne findig islam muss man sehen
wie wir das praktiziert wie wird es
gelebt und und dass ich einfach es wird
nicht der islam gelebt sondern es werden
unterschiedliche formen von islam gelebt
und verletzt sich in einer bosnischen
moschee da wird mir sehr deutlich betont
die frau des imams sagt mir wir sind
europäische muslime wir gehören schon
seit langem dazu wo wir werden sozusagen
fremd nach außen gedrängt und in dem
sinne find ich der islam ist eine
kategorie die uns eigentlich in dem
gesellschaftlichen gespräch diskurs
nicht weiterhilft sondern eine negativ
stadt lohne aufgestellt ist diese zahl
um vereinbar ist mit schweizer behörden
schweizer demokratieverständnis aber in
einem verständnis was hier in prozessen
gesellschaftlichen prozessen läuft ist
dies eigentlich nicht hilfreich und
führt auch nicht weit aber interessant
ist doch dass diese frage stark wenn
islam gestellt wird aber hoeren selten
hindus sind integriert und der
hinduismus lässt sich nicht integrieren
das liegt auch daran dass jede
gesellschaft hat schon ein platz für
eine fremde religion zugezogene religion
in der gesellschaft gemacht windows
vietnamesische buddhisten tibetische
buddhisten sagen auf der positiven seite
sie werden nicht hinterfragt tibetische
buddhisten amenda lama der ist gerade in
basel war so werde ich ihn gefragt warum
werden sind nicht gefragt ja das ist
natürlich fall die gesellschaft sich
auch bestimmte bilder von den religionen
macht und sie auch gerne so hat dann und
wir haben den islam war in den 20er
jahren beim 19 jahrhundert zum teil das
war sehr verherrlichend war sozusagen
das bild von 1001 nacht es war bei
intellektuellen in deutschland zum teil
in der schweiz war islam sozusagen als
rationale natur wissenschaftlich
fundiert religion die auf viel mit
wissenschaften arbeitet da kommt die
mathematik war zum teil auch sehr den in
der zeit war sehr positiv angesehen und
natürlich jetzt mit den
terror-anschlägen nach 2001 hatte sich
sehr gedreht und politisch ist es das
sieht man nicht nur in der schweiz wir
sehen wir in anderen europäischen
ländern ist islam eine folie über die
hervorragend mobilisiert werden kann
weil wir einen fremden haben den können
wir an eine bestimmte ecke stellen wenn
du uns muslime selber anschauen wenn wir
uns die webseiten wenn wir mit ihm reden
zu sagen natürlich stehen wir dazu der
schweizer gesellschaft wir haben auf den
webseiten vorne drauf bekenntnis zur
schweizer rechts gesellschaft zu
demokratie und
aber wir werden nicht gefragt sondern es
werden bestimmte schablonen dann oft
gezeigt in der politischen gespräche und
das würde dann auch heißen dass die
anderen religionsgemeinschaften so etwas
aus dem fokus geraten und sich
vielleicht so in diesem wink schatten
der islam diskussion eigenständiger
reformieren können nicht ich nenne ein
beispiel wir haben kürzlich erfahren die
hinter gemeinde im haus der religion in
bern will einführen dass auch frauen
priesterinnen werden können ändert die
sprache vom sanskrit zum
umgangssprachlichen camenisch warum ist
da das reformtempo in den
religionsgemeinschaften zu
unterschiedlich
ich glaube man schaut jetzt sehr
deutlich auf diesen tempel in wären weil
er sozusagen genau das bild bedient dass
viele schweizer auch politiker
vielleicht religionsvertreter haben
sozusagen ein ein modern hinduismus oder
reformierten hinduismus der frauen
gleich stellt und so etwas wir übersehen
aber die anderen 20 templeton den sehr
viel passiert auch in der auch
jugendliche eingezogen werden in der
frauen zum teil unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten haben ich würde sagen
reform tempel wir sehen in dem muss muss
stehen auch viele reformen in dem
beispielsweise imame plötzlich rollen
annehmen müssen die sie in den
herkunftsregionen
gar nicht haben sie sind plötzlich
berater seelsorger sie sind mitunter ein
jobvermittler also
reformtempo
für dich für dich nicht so sehen sondern
das ist jetzt ein sozialen besonderer
fall mit dem hindutempel und wir sehen
der jetzt in den medien gepusht wird es
passiert doch noch fiel aber ich denke
die anderen tempel wenn ich jetzt in
dürnten oberland c mädchen u10 den
tempel sehe dort ist versucht man auch
viel sozusagen sich hier in die
gesellschaft einzubringen und
mitzumachen denn viel zu schulklassen zu
öffnen für führungen zu öffnen ähnliches
wir werden uns darüber noch unterhalten
jetzt hören erst einmal drei stimmen von
jungen muslimen und was ist für sie
heißt ihre religion hier und heute
zulegen
gemäss für mäßig
und findet dass lahm ist was er schon
kann man
ohne angst
dass ich nicht aus das weiß ich
der glaube ist eine
lebensart und der laden sicherlich und
dort geht es für mich persönlich
lief jetzt der nötige antwort aber man
sich halt im verlauf vom nabu ausstellt
aber es ist für mehr privat sehr
persönlich es also
nicht mit brüsten oder nach außen trage
ist es wirklich und theater
wir migrantinnen mit 8 jährige schweizer
und für mich das nicht immer einfach sie
aus ring und aus junge frau ist zwischen
zwei kulturen auf
22 wachsen ja sehr lang im körper
nirgendwo habe also ich habe mit
albanisch mazedonisch geführt wir nicht
richtig schwitzen ist wo objekt benehmen
russland xi und haben innerhalb sondern
kann man ihr wirklich mit mir selber
auseinandergesetzt und auch mit eigener
identität gesucht
und da nicht merkt dass religion
wirklich viel mehr bedeutet für mich
aussie aussie das war bis dahin
ja martin baumann das sind drei sehr
unterschiedliche stimmen mir fällt aber
auch auf dass alle drei ein positives
verhältnis formulieren in bezug auf ihre
religion und dass sie sich irgendwo
zwischen religion als lifestyle und
religion als identität bewegen ist das
nun typisch für muslime oder eher
typisch für die zweite generation
ich denke das ist typisch für die zweite
generation was wir in dem fall gesehen
habe in den 23 sozusagen ausschnitten
ist aussagen von personen die für die
religion sozusagen ein vehikel ist ein
weg um identität zu finden sein platz in
der gesellschaft sozusagen zu wissen wo
man steht
der zweite mann war sozusagen sehr
religiös für ihn war religion ein
lebensweg und erste porträt von der
jungen dame war in dem sinne sehr
anschaulich dass das zeigte wie
distanziert man gegenüber religion ist
und bestimmte regeln vorschrift manchmal
kein alkohol zu trinken im islam das
überschreitet und wir sehen eigentlich
bei vielen zweit generation sei es
jungen tibetern jung muslim jungen hindu
das dass wir so eine ein spektrum haben
von von personen die sehr distanziert
gegenüber religion sind und welchen
diese sehr religiös sind für die das
wichtig ist wo diese zwei pole die n
pole sind quasi minderheiten sehr
deutlich minderheiten und die großen
bereich sehen wir in personen
jugendlichen die die selektiv religiösen
so haben wir das genannt die mal in die
moschee gehen mal in die hindu tempel
aber für sie ist es jetzt nicht so
lebens bestimmt es ist eine form weil
man ihn mit den eltern gehen mit anderen
freunden dort hingeht falls bestimmten
tageszeiten bestimmten festen aber man
sozusagen auch diesen diesen spagat
zwischen der welt der eltern den
migranten gemeinschaft und eben der
angebotene hiesigen gesellschaft mit
konsumgesellschaft und ähnlichen diesen
spagat schafft und das so interpretiert
für sich indem man distanziert und
selektiv ist dass wir jetzt gleich meine
nächste frage gewesen sie besuchen ja
auch häufig die religionsgemeinschaften
verschiedener hindurch sicher oder
buddhistischer ausrichtungen was erleben
sie da gehen junge tamilische männer und
frauen junge buddhisten tibeter gehen
die noch so selbstverständlich in den
tempel und pflegen gemeinschaft die das
ihre eltern getan haben nein eigentlich
nicht also man sieht ja sehr deutlich
den unterschied wer wo aufgewachsen wo
sozialisiert ist für die eltern hat wenn
wir das beispiel eines hindu-tempels
nimmt beim videoschnitt tempels ist
dieser tempel auch sehr deutlich eine
gemeinschaft tamilisch gesprochen da
wird sozusagen auch rückbindung an nach
sri lanka an die herkunft an die
heimatliche kultur und religion gesucht
für die zweite generation ist wie sagte
dass jemand sind die rituale langweilig
sie dauern lange sie sind unverständlich
es wird noch mit rauch gearbeitet
götter verehrt und so und wir sehen
mitunter dass die die mädchen sozusagen
sind gebeten dann auch mit den müttern
im tempel zu bleiben die jungs bleiben
draußen vor dem tempel bis auf wenige
ausnahmen schwitzen
und unterhalten sich über verschiedene
dinge sei es über fußball über mädchen
und kommt zum ende der pusher der
andacht rein da gibt es den segen hinter
gibt es das essen aber es ist eine ganz
andere einstellung und sie sagen heimat
ist für uns hier die schweiz und ist
nicht mehr sri lanka und wenn ich in sri
lanka bin war das ist für mich sozusagen
ein urlaub aber ein leben das könnte ich
nicht sie haben auch untersucht wie sich
religiöse jugendgruppen verhalten und
wir uns jetzt vor augen halten für den
kirchlichen bereich die zivis blauring
organisationen die sind bekannt
anerkannt und ihre arbeit wird auch sehr
geschätzt aber schon wenn wir von
jüdischen jugendorganisationen oder dann
muslimischen jugendorganisationen partys
beispielsweise hören dann denken wir
doch sofort ist das jetzt nötig oder ist
das eine form der abgrenzung warum
braucht das
sie sind eigentlich weit geht erst
einmal unbekannt was da läuft man muss
aber auch sagen ist eine minderheit ist
eine minderheit wir haben ungefähr wenn
die schätzungen wenn man sagen kann die
100.000 20.000 junge muslime jugendliche
junge erwachsene muslime und jan
plusminus 100 jugendvereine gefunden das
ist extrem wenig wir sehen es sind zehn
vielleicht 15 prozent von muslimen
machen überhaupt in diesen vereinen mit
der großteil nicht also 85 prozent
möglicherweise machen nicht wegen dann
die mitmachenden zivilgesellschaftlichen
organisationen nicht sie sind in
sportvereinen drin sie sind in der wäre
drin sie engagieren sich in der schule
dass sie dort gute resultate zu bekommen
sie sind im konsumverhalten drin wie
viele andere schweizer jugendliche auch
dann wir sehen das in diesen und auf die
jugendgruppen zurückzukommen wir sehen
das in diesem jugendgruppen amtlich
aktivitäten sehr ähnlich sind wie bei
jugend blauring bei den pfadis apple
kirchlichen vereinen
freizeitaktivitäten wir sehen dass hier
aktivitäten wie sport anlässe wie steht
anlässen so etwas organisiert wird aber
der unterschied ist es werden auch
religiöse inhalte vermittelt selbst
vermittelt die jugendlichen sind selber
miteinander lehrer aber beispielsweise
eine gruppe
versucht den oder ließ den koran erklärt
sich bestimmte dinge lädt man referenten
ein
mann hält selbstverständlich die
gebetszeiten 1 bei einem islamischen
jugendturnier fußball turnier haben wir
gesehen dass dort auch wird sagen die
sportkleidung relativ dezent war auch
dort gebetszeiten eingehalten wurden und
auch die geschlechtertrennung relativ
stark und deutlich war das heißt in
diesen jugendorganisation
herrscht ein bisschen die die
vorstellung ganz oder gar nicht entweder
organisiert man sich in der gesellschaft
und dann ist man nicht in diesen
jugendorganisation oder wenn man dort
dabei ist dann gibt es sehr wenige zu
und her nein das sehen wir nicht sondern
wir sehen es gibt eigentlich sehr
weniger hoch gelegt mit jugendgruppen
weil das ist nicht attraktiv für
jugendliche jugendliche gehen hin weil
es offen ist falls interessant ist dort
aktivitäten angeboten wenn die jugend
orientiert sind und wo wir aber auch
aussagen haben wo anna sagte hier kann
ich mich mit anderen über die
problematik über die schwierigkeit
einfach auszutauschen in der schweiz ein
muslim zu sein und wie ich mein leben
leben was kann ich essen warum muss ich
muss mich nicht mehr begründen dass ich
kein alkohol trinke und ähnliches da und
es sind eigentlich vereine die werden
nicht in den untersuchungen gesehen dass
wir jetzt sozusagen hoch religiöse
vielleicht welche abkapseln wird sondern
wir sehen jugendvereine die
das vielleicht auch die minderheit aber
versuchen sich interreligiösen dialog
einzubringen wir sehen meint wegen wo
man mit einer christlichen jugend gruppe
zusammen eine
anlass durchführt und sagt was heißt für
mich muslim sein was heißt für mich
christ sein aber wie sehen eigentlich
den grad von zusagen engagement der ist
ähnlich wie bei anderen jugendvereinen
christlich geprägte oder nicht
christlich geprägter vereine und wir
sehen aber nicht zu einer abschottung
sondern wir sehen das ist ein ort in dem
kraft geschöpft wird und dem das war das
letzte porträt von der jungen dame und
seiner identität geschaffen wird wo man
weiß hier kirchen das gehört für mich
und ich kann religiös sein und in der
gesellschaft teilzuhaben meine lehre
mein beruf zu machen kann ich sehr gut
miteinander verbinden das wird auch
heißen dass das vielleicht eher so eine
vorübergehende attraktion darstellt die
jugendliche die dort sich aufgehoben
fühlen und sich austauschen sicherlich
wir sehen eben wenn jugendliche älter
werden sie verlassen aufgrund
familienbildung aufgrund von aufnahmen
von studium von beruflichen engagement
sehen wir dass die jugendgruppen
verlassen wir sind einige jugendliche
die bleiben in den jugendgruppen drin
helfen hier wieder jüngeren und das
denke ich sind ganz wichtige rolle also
vorbilder und sie sagen auch wenn jemand
sagt warum soll ich diese al gore
mathematik lösung und um rechenaufgaben
machen dann sagt ein älterer
jugendlicher sagt schau ich lerne auch
noch ich bin hier an der universität
oder ich bin in der höheren lehre und
und über bildung nur schaffst du den
sozusagen teil zu werden und teil hier
in der gesellschaft fuß zu fassen und
auch einen guten job zu haben
die bedeutung der institutionellen
religion nimmt tendenziell ab bei uns in
der gesellschaft trotzdem betonen sie
oder wird in diesem buch auch betont
dass religionsgemeinschaften einen
zivilgesellschaftlichen nutzen haben wir
können uns einen nutzen vorstellen der
nutzen ist in dem er erst mal person
einbindet bindet person ein stellt
kontakte her und über was wir gerade
eben in dem buch was wir betonen ist
eben gerade christliche gruppen partie
großen landeskirchen aber auch
freikirchen
sind sehr engagiert um auch soziale
missstände in der gesellschaft
aufzuheben und jetzt endlich in einer
gesellschaft für die schweiz ist die
sehr starke zivilgesellschaft
organisiert ist geht dies über
institutionen geht es über vereine
freiwilligen vereine wir sehen eben in
der schweiz auch dass diese freiwilligen
engagement nach und nach eigentlich
zurückgeht das hängt natürlich sehr
stark mit individualisierung zu tun und
zusammen und konsumgesellschaft das in
andere angebote würden sie denn ganz
konkret
jugendlichen empfehlen die sich in
religiösen gemeinschaften engagieren
dies ist als ein mehrwert hervorzuheben
beispielsweise bei einer lehrstelle
bewerben ich würde das hervorheben aber
ich finds begründen ja nicht weil
sozusagen in den köpfen ist natürlich
das bild islamische jugendgruppe ist das
abgeschottete das radikalisiert aber
wenn ich schreibe ich bin in einer
muslimischen jugendgruppe und habe ich
hier gemacht hausaufgabenhilfe ich habe
organisiert einen interreligiösen dialog
anlass ich habe organisierten ausflug
nach dortmund dorthin das zeigt diese
person ist übernimmt verantwortung und
kann organisieren und was wir sehen was
in den jugendgruppen läuft vielfach ist
verantwortung übernehmen organisieren
lernen und das ist natürlich
zivilgesellschaftliche fähigkeiten
gesellschaft kapital was man auch in
anderen bereichen
gebrauchen kann sei es im studium sei es
im beruf sei es in den bereichen wenn
man in politischen parteien oder
ähnliches geht bleiben wir ganz kurz bei
der frage des kapitals erkennt unserer
gesellschaft diese anlage diese diese
diese nötige investitionen ist das
kapital ich glaube noch nicht ich glaube
sie kennen das sehr gut bei christlichen
jugendgruppen sie kennt er sehr gut bei
blaubeuren jugendring weil bei blauen
jungwacht bei den pfadi seppel und
ähnlichen dann da kennt sie das sehr gut
aber sie sieht wird dann aus ihrer
perspektive heraus mit dem negativ folie
islam sieht sie noch nicht dass
ähnliches eigentlich läuft auch in
muslimischen jugend gruppen auch in
tibetischen jugendgruppen oder
vietnamesisch buddhistischen
jugendgruppen hier wird organisiert und
dies organisieren lernen sich vor einer
gruppe stellen und zu sagen lasst uns
diskutieren lasst uns dies machen
organisieren jemand anzurufen dinge auf
die beine zu stellen das glaub ich es
wird mit der zeit stärker kommt ich sehe
es in den lokalen gemeinden dass
beispielsweise
integrationsbeauftragte sind oft sehr
gut
informiert sie wissen darüber aber auf
der bisschen höheren politischen seite
dann wird sehr schnell dieses argument
religion ausgrenzt nicht zugehören
instrumentalisiert und und dann sind da
mit blockaden auch gelaufen ich glaube
wir müssen schauen was läuft in den
religiösen vereinen was läuft in den
jugendgruppen um dies einmal sozusagen
auch weniger von der religion zu sehen
sondern von den aktivitäten hier wir
kommen bereits schon zum schluss und
meine letzte frage wäre die nach dem
ausblick in die zukunft wohin läuft der
trend bei der dritten und später auch
vierten generation was die bedeutung der
religion angelangt es kann sein wie wir
aus amerikanischen studien wissen dass
die dritte rallye dritte generation
möglicherweise religiöser wird sozusagen
diese distanzierung zurücknimmt und und
und sagt wir möchten mehr an die wurzeln
der eltern an das herkunftsland es kann
aber auch sein dass dieser trend der der
ich gesellschaft wie mein kollege dass
jörg stolz gesagt hat dieser trend der
ich gesellschaft der konsumgesellschaft
weiter stark anhält und und die leute
noch mehr sich von religion distanzieren
und ich glaube was wir von der
gesellschaft seite her ihnen müssen ich
glaube wir müssen diesen diesen effekt
von religion ii sierung sozusagen die
religion auflegen auf leute auf stirbt
auf eine man muss es einfach bisschen
nicht dann habe ich es ein entspannter
sehen und sehen es ist nicht religionen
sozusagen per se positiv oder oder
negativ sondern man muss einfach schauen
wie wie stark ist religion an hier drin
und nicht und diese religion easy rolle
eigentlich die zurücknehmen und schauen
was sehen wir vor ort und was ist
wirklich vorzufinden sie werden die
entwicklungen weiter verfolgen wie ihr
auch ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei
ihnen für dieses gespräch
dann gehen auch sie mal
mit dem film den wir jetzt zeigen
bleiben wir beim thema ich bin ein
berliner sagte einst der amerikanische
präsident john f kennedy ich bin ein
berliner oder eine berlinerin sagen auch
die drei jungen menschen die sie gleich
kennenlernen werden einer hat
kongolesische eine iranische und der
dritte
jüdische wurzeln